as we continue joining us now with
reactions at tonight's opening monologue
Fox News contributor investigative
reporter Sarah Carter Fox News legal
analyst gregg jarrett former deputy
assistant to the president Fox News
national security strategist sebastian
Gorka all right Greg I'll just let you
respond to everything today and the only
thing I'm going to say is the only
thinks shocking to me is that anybody is
shocked because we have been telling
everybody about Russia's work influence
dirty deeds in this country now for a
long time and the rest of the media has
been literally ignoring the biggest
story in their life if they could open
their eyes you know this shouldn't come
as a surprise to anybody who has read
the DNI report that came out a year ago
in January in which they detail over the
course of decades the Russians and
before them the Soviets efforts to sow
discord in disruption and chaos in
democracies especially America why
they're an authoritarian government they
hate democracies but you could hear the
collective groan today across the nation
among Democrats and the liberal media
they were so disappointed that when
Rosenstein stepped to the podium he said
not a word about Trump Russian collusion
you know the FBI has been at it for a
year and a half they found out a shred
of it a mother's been at it since last
May and apparently hasn't found any
evidence of it but don't be surprised by
what happened today this doesn't mean
that Muller is shifting away from Trump
no his eyes are squarely on Donald Trump
if they can't find evidence of collusion
Muller will likely try to pursue a case
of obstruction which doesn't trade yeah
I said let's see the let's see the Comey
memos
he said Exhibit A for the defense yeah
exculpatory relation
I'm sure it's absolutely exculpatory
because at the time come he was writing
them he didn't envision being fired he's
an arrogant guy never it never occurred
to him that he would be although he
certainly deserved to be all right Sarah
the end of the day the the Russians
actually campaigned for
and against Donald Trump in this whole
thing that's what what an irony
they wanted a so discord just like I
guess they were able to manipulate
America and the Obama administration to
get 20% of our uranium which everyone
else ignores well this is what they do
this is the Russians modus operandi and
anybody who works in intelligence
understands this I think that this will
go beyond what this a 16 count
indictment revealed that they were doing
this back in 2014 as far as our election
system but I think what we're going to
discover is that the dossier was also
part of their disinformation campaign
and that the Russians work diligently to
pass disinformation to Christopher
Steele they were utilizing Fuzion GPS
and guess what shine the media
journalists and mainstream media
American media actually fed into this
campaign and they were unwittingly being
used by the Russians over the past year
and that's really a shame because that's
something they should have been
investigating from the beginning this is
how Russians do this I mean they were
very secure about it tick-tock there's a
lot more to come about how they were
manipulated how they were engaged with
the with the Clinton campaign dr. Gork I
think my favorite is the the day they
had approached rump rally that they
organized and an anti Trump rally in the
same city on the same day that speaks
volumes that's what they do
that's what they do they disrupt other
people's democracies but let's be clear
what happened today Sean today 13
Russians were indicted and three legal
entities nothing's going to happen with
that because they're Russians and
they're over there and we can't
extradite them I've got a tip for robert
muller
some other people messed with our
elections and they're right here in
america
there's hillary clinton there's the DNC
there's fusion GPS and that's here in
Hillary's lawyer they messed with the
election they stole the candidacy from
Bernie Sanders and then they gave false
information to a FISA Court
so mr. Muller if you want to actually
put some people in prison
start with the Americans that perverted
our election
here in America well-said damage the
damage to the bureau and and to the
bureau's reputation that people within
the FBI now we know we've seen clear
evidence of that Peter struck Lisa Paige
Andrew McCabe others James Baker the
general counsel that there were people
clearly within the FBI who had an agenda
and that was not their role this is you
know not the Politburo this is not
Russia and that appears to be how it was
being run wait a minute you mean mccabe
and call me and struck and Loretta Lynch
and Paige just to name a few you mean
they had an agenda
you mean they exonerated Hillary I can't
wait for the IG report to come out and
if the IG does his job then that means
the fix was in the process was screwed
and it was all set up and rigged from
day one great we don't know X provide
them I've talked to four former FBI
officials who are in close contact with
current FBI agents and they the rank and
file are angry they're not angry at the
media they're exposing this they're
angry at James Comey Andrew McCabe Viki
struck Paige the whole gang high
officials in management at the FBI and
some of the Department of Justice who
have shredded the good name and hard
work of the people who do the real job
and carry a badge and gun and try to
protect our lives we're getting to the
truth in part without revealing sources
and methods to use a phrase of late
because of some honest FBI guys some
honest people in the intelligence
community did Sarah I know who our
sources are in some cases dr. Gorka as
as you look at this and we see where do
you think this Muller is going I see a
guy that is blinding his ambition that
has hired a team of of DNC Obama Hillary
sycophants anti-trump activists that are
like on a mission to destroy this
president don't forget one thing
Robert Muller escorted by his bosom
buddy rod Rosenstein went to the White
House to interview for the job of
Director of the FBI with President
Donald Trump he failed
he didn't get the interview the next day
rod makes him special prosecutor special
counsel don't you think he's got an
agenda absolutely this is this is
revenge for Robert Mahler but we can't
let him pervert justice like everybody
else on the 7th floor all right what
about Andrew Weissman he you were not
only did he get beaten by the Supreme
Court overturned nine zero and the Fifth
Circuit Court of Appeals this this piece
you wrote today Sarah this guy twice has
withheld evidence in cases and this is
what the New York Times describes as as
Muller's pit bull
well is he even there well because he
and Moeller have been longtime
acquaintances very close friends they
work together he was in the general
counsel at the FBI under Robert Moeller
he has a lot of faith in him I guess
that he can take a case and run with it
no matter what uh you'd have to ask you
know Special Counsel Moeller why because
if you look back to 1997 and he was
directly reprimanded and then his name
was withdrawn from that reprimand I mean
he was going to be reported to the bar
not only did he not inform the jury that
you know the person that he had up there
the witness was an informant for the FBI
he also had an FBI agent that was
apparently dirty and who was indicted
later for orders I want Robert Muller to
explain to America how a guy that
withheld evidence in two cases and lost
nine zero in the Supreme Court sent
people to jail for a year overturned by
the Fifth Circuit why was he ever
appointed to be his pit bull
I want that answer it's a it's a great
question and robert muller will never
answer it because the answer wouldn't be
good he wanted a pit bull a guy would
weaponize the law he got it and who
would bend and twist the rules you could
fill volumes with the complaints that
have been filed against Andrew Weissman
and the cases that been overturned and
his repeated attempts as successfully to
conceal evidence and intimidate
witnesses I could keep you guys on all
night
great job everybody will absorb all this
we'll reconvene on Monday you guys have
a great we